[Music]
hello this is an interview with the
authors of the paper on active dendrites
now if you haven't seen it i've made a
comprehensive paper review video on this
paper and i released that yesterday if
you watch this video as it comes out
which obviously you do today i'm going
to interview the authors and we've all
seen my review so we'll be able to
directly dive in so if you haven't seen
the review yet and you want to know
what's in the paper maybe that is a good
place to start the authors here were
really helpful and really informative
answering all of my questions and
concerns that i had and even bringing up
some new interesting insights so i hope
you learn something from this interview
or at least that it entertains you and
if you have any comments please let me
know in the comments below the video
i'll see you around bye-bye hey there
today's sponsor is the course on
introduction to graph neural networks
this is a course by my friend zach jost
who is an expert in graph neural
networks and also runs the welcome ai
overlords youtube channel has a very
interesting blog and does many other
cool things he's packed all his
knowledge of graph neural networks into
one course that will educate you on both
the theoretical and hands-on practical
aspect on graph neural networks graph
neural networks are really important
they're definitely one of the most
interesting areas in deep learning right
now they're on the upswing they model
data that has an underlying structure
that is connected that is not really
well fit for any of the classic formats
like tables or images they've also
powered a lot of recent advances in
scientific breakthroughs such as alpha
fold protein structure predictions or
better traffic predictions so if you're
interested in graph neural network i'll
definitely recommend you check out that
course if you use my link you'll get a
15
discount on the course enrollment is
open right now and lasts until april 1st
or until spaces run out the courses is
six weeks course it's cohort based
you'll get access to a community to
discord community of other students and
you'll get all the materials and
hands-on experience all right let's get
into the video now see ya
[Music]
hi everyone today i'm here with the
three joint first authors of the paper
on active dendrites abi karan and akash
and i'm very very happy to have you all
here this paper covers many areas it
covers biology it covers neural networks
it covers kind of different
architectures of stuff it's very cool
that you all sort of are here and and
are able to sort of answer my questions
welcome all of you
yeah thanks janik
thanks for having me thanks for having
us
it's very it's a very interesting paper
so i saw this paper and i was intrigued
because
um
it's not often that a lot of people say
they do biologically inspired things
but it's not often that someone really
goes and says look you know here's
what's missing let's build it in and
then it actually leads to something that
that works and that is uh
you know the hypothesis in your paper
the hypotheses you pose on what should
happen are actually confirmed at the end
and this is i think a very good story
arc for a paper and a really nice thing
to write up um so
is this is this how did this come to be
how did you get the idea of bringing
these very too distant not too distant
but these two distant fields together of
of sort of neuro neurobiology
and deep learning
well at numenta um we're interested one
of the things we're interested in is in
continual learning and and
learning multi multiple tasks more
generally speaking and so um you know
we're looking
but but a lot of neural networks and
deep learning today focuses on
trying to solve a single task so we said
well you know how is biology enabling um
the ability to solve multiple things in
sequence or you know at the same time
learning different things and so
and so you know
from there's been a lot of work out
there on active dendrites and so and
it's not exactly clear what their role
was um but
a little while back we speculated that
hey they might actually be helping um at
the at the neural level to um
to allow for
for continual learning and so if we can
build this idea
into um deep learning then there might
be some um there might be some uh
prospect there for
addressing problems like continual
learning and multi-task learning so is
it fair to say that it grew out of sort
of a need to solve a task
i think it grow out of the need to solve
multiple tasks
in sequence either
learning them together or or in sequence
continuously um to add on to to what
karen was saying is that
we believe that active dendrites can
really aid in achieving these
specialized neural circuits and we can
apply these ideas directly to any neural
network and show some competitive
performance on uh on various benchmarks
that involve continual learning setups
so i guess the purpose of this project
if you were to just summarize it very
briefly is we just want to show a proof
of concept for a new idea that can allow
deep learning to work in more dynamic
and uh dynamic environments and
scenarios
to kind of add on to what karen and abby
said so at a higher level i think we
were kind of examining where
a lot of modern
deep networks fail and that's in these
like streaming task settings and
multi-task settings
and
the kind of like
inspiration for our solution was
directed towards biology and biological
neurons which is a lot of what numentus
focuses on
and i think
um
quite nicely we found these like
there are existing benchmarks and
existing tasks that show that typical
deep learning networks fail in these
scenarios and we were able to build in
these like
biologically inspired neurons to
improve the performance in in such
dynamic settings
by using the fact that we believe active
dendrites in in biology kind of do this
kind of
um
context dependent
adaptation in multiple tasks
what i found interesting is that even
though you you targeted a little bit
towards multi-layered perceptrons in
principle the this uh
active dendrites architecture is sort of
pluggable almost anywhere so you could
always
imagine some sort of a context dependent
signal that gets routed in and modulates
the signal that exists so
i think
what i'm trying to find out is there are
a number of things happening in this
model there is first of all the
modulation itself which is a relatively
it's not really a known concept at least
in classical deep learning we always
have weighted sums we rarely have the
situation where
two two parts of the signal are
multiplied together or one modulates the
other it happens a little bit in lstms
and so on the other one is this sort of
recognition of a context and
and
you know
being context dependent and then a third
thing is this
the sparsity
now
you have sort of combined all of them is
there
one thing that you think is specifically
important or is it sort of the
combination of things that is really
what makes the difference you have some
ablations in the paper uh what can you
say about this i think it's it's the
combination of all these things acting
together so it's the it's the it's the
dendrites which are you know up
modulating and down modulating certain
neurons to determine which ones should
become
um which which to determine which
sub-network should be invoked and then
it's the sparsity on top of that which
is ensuring that you know a large
portion of the network is essentially
not performing or learning a certain
task it's those two things um together
which which
which really
um
gets at this idea of using specialized
sub networks for different things so i
wouldn't say it's any any one um one
thing that stands out more than the
others
so when we get let's get into the paper
itself uh you've seen my review of it uh
with respect to just framing the problem
and maybe framing the the architecture
as such is there do you think i have
captured what you've tried to say do you
think i've left something important out
or or have put emphasis on
or have not put emphasis on something
that you would like to put emphasis on
when it comes to like what the
architecture is what it does and how it
works
i think your explanations for the
architecture at least we're very good i
think it does definitely does capture
what we're trying to trying to say um
and the whole point to kind of reiterate
is that the same model with the same
principles should work on
completely separate areas one is the
multi-task reinforcement learning the
other one is continual learning with
permuted amnest
and i think you touched upon that idea
too so
yeah i think that the kind of motivation
that
if you i think you in towards the
beginning of your review you kind of
compared
the
typical weighted linear sum neuron with
uh the active dendrites neuron
and i think
our motivation in coming up with this
architecture was how can we incorporate
a lot of these properties into active
dendrites with having like
uh
dendrite dendritic segments being able
to either like up modulate or down
modulate certain neurons
in a way that didn't like completely go
like it completely changed from like
normal back propagation trainable
networks so like this architecture kind
of brings in
that
that flavor of having dendrites
influence certain neurons but does so in
a way that mathematically allows for
back propagation to
train train the networks and i think you
touched on that pretty well as well
do you think uh do you think it's valid
to sort of bring in biological concepts
even though we train with back
propagation because you know
it's it's very evident that at least
pure like
correct back propagation isn't happening
in the brain do you think
you know it's still valid to bring in
the concepts and maybe the brain is
doing something like back prop or uh do
you think we're sort of just kind of
taking inspiration from biology in in
order to solve some of our problems
i think it's
i think it's more so the latter um
[Music]
of course the most accurate biological
neural network would likely not use back
propagation right
but this is one area where i think
the goal was can we make deep learning
just a little bit more plausible and in
doing so can can we make it a little bit
more dynamic
um
so we're not necessarily here to uh to
to remove backprop entirely um and say
that that's the best way that um the
dendrites in this architecture can work
although certainly that's that is how it
works in biology um the point was can we
just augment traditional deep neural
nets to work in uh in more dynamic
scenarios
now i had some criticisms with respect
to just
make like details of your architecture
for example you always or you often
choose the number of dendritic segments
to match the number of tasks that you
that you have which obviously
if i was a researcher i would do the
same but can you say maybe something
about how this how this is in in the
brain like how what numbers are we
talking about how many of these of these
sub networks that are composed of distal
you know dendrites how many are there um
approximately do you do do you know do
you have an idea and you know what can
you say about you know how many we
should build into a problem where we
maybe don't know how many tasks we
expect
there are um from what i recall probably
in the order of 100 hundreds or
thousands of individual um dendrite
segments for
each individual neuron actually that
might even it might even be more than
that um
the the actual numbers escape me um but
regarding what you said earlier about um
you know having the number of tasks be
equal to the number of segments here
we i mean we we found that actually even
though in a lot of the experiments we
report here we do set the number of
segment dendrites to the number of
tasks we found that you know we actually
don't need to have that many and we
actually have further studies um
which show that you know we can actually
keep the architecture fixed and increase
the number of
tasks we're doing i'm talking about
continual learning here because for a
multi-task we're focused on 10
specifically we can increase the number
of tasks and yet we're and then and the
the performance actually doesn't change
by much so that shows that you know as
we're as we're
as we're
increasing the number of dendrite
segments we actually end up over
parameterizing the network quite a bit
which we don't need to do
yeah so this is the the plot on the left
right here you just increase the number
of dendritic segments and the top line
is learning 10 tasks and it doesn't get
noticeably worse which i find to be very
cool property right like i don't want to
have to set the parameter
very specifically i can just you know
set it too high and it doesn't hurt
which is cool which leads me to the plot
on the right where you discuss you know
the sparsity
i'm going to guess that's the sparsity
parameter so that's the thing that
ultimately controls k right
and i find it peculiar
not that there is an optimal setting
which i would expect because
that i can't set high that'd have to set
between like zero and one right so
there's going to be like some optimum in
between but this there's this like two
two bump thing going on so what's going
on there why is it like really good at
low like high sparsity and then there's
like this plateau and then it just flat
like
crashes down
i think
they're in in the beginning um you know
if you have if you have too much um
sorry i always think in terms of
sparsity so i'm converting from density
to sparsity so if you have no if it's
too sparse right there's not enough
signal going through and that's why you
know as you as you increase the amount
of signal that you're allowing through
if you're increasing the capacity of
your representation then you're going to
get
you're going to get an increase in
performance but then if you have if
you're using up too many units to to
create that uh to create that
representation then you're going to get
more interference right and as you have
more interference you're going to you're
going to you're going to forget more
more network parameters are overwritten
as you uh move on to subsequent tasks
and so you get a drop in accuracy and
towards the end so
you know you notice that it does fall
drastically
honestly i haven't thought too much
about to why that happens although it is
it is a pretty pretty monotonic fall
even though i guess in that in that
upper curve there is a slight bump and
that could just be due to uh seeding or
something like that but
yeah yeah i was more referring to like
the plateau itself right there is
there's this plateau
kind of and i i know i know that there
could be almost like two two modes of
using the sparsity in one mode i have
entire sub networks that do the job and
in the other mode i have like a shared
network
yet i have like separate things that
just kind of like track
track which task i'm on
um which would sort of correspond to
what the baseline is doing right when
people say well the baseline has access
to the task too it can just allocate
some units
uh no it it's maybe not a perfect
analogy but i was just wondering it was
just uh interesting to see that there's
this kind of this type of plateau
yeah that's that's something i guess we
haven't
gone too deep into but this might um
this might just be a property of sparse
representations and how and how much
overlap there is as you as you inc as
you um increase the
sparsity level it could just be
something to do with that
so in your paper you make really which i
appreciate you make really sure that you
sort of always have the same amount of
let's say trainable parameters in your
architectures and you show that by
arranging them correctly you can you can
achieve a better result
you always use this
name of non-zero parameters right is
there like is there a difference are
there large swaths of zero parameters
in one or the of one of these
architectures
yeah so this is something that we
control for um in the beginning this is
why we mentioned the idea of weight
sparsity so in the beginning when when
we're actually creating the architecture
from scratch we decide that some layers
have an x percent sparsity level applied
to it and what that really means is that
x percent of the parameters are zero
throughout the entire
part of training um and even towards the
end so that's why we we express
everything in non-zero parameters so the
mlps for instance at least in
reinforcement learning are trained with
no weight sparsity so it's completely
dense there are no zeros anywhere in the
in the layers
and and then the
your your architecture you sort of
modulate the amount of sparsity and that
is on top of modulating the k parameter
of the k winner takes all layers
yeah there's two aspects to the sparsity
so one is activation sparsity which
is like at a hidden like when you have a
hidden state vector how many neurons
remain non-zero after the activation is
applied which is a k-winder
activation and then the second aspect of
sparsity is weight sparsity which is how
connected are subsequent layers in the
network um so if a lot of the units in
the weight matrix are zero then this
model is the fact that
subsequent layers in in the network are
not very connected they're sparsely
connected
to to i guess answer your question again
on that is um it's not something weight
sparsity at least is something that it's
not something we modulate it's fixed
it's a fixed percentage that we find um
and this can either be done through
fine-tuning or just yeah just just
experimentation
okay because i i think yeah i might i
might have just overread that but but i
recall that in the introduction you say
you know both the weights and the both
the weights and the uh
the activations are sparse but then sort
of the i think the winner takes all
really focuses on the on the activations
itself have you experimented with
setting
you know something else then k to a
number or a percentage uh setting maybe
a threshold for sparsity or something
like this where whenever a signal is
strong enough it is
let through
we haven't we haven't done anything like
that
but we could do that and you know there
is a chance that um it could work out
pretty well if we if we have a fixed
threshold but one potential downside
there is that
you know if you have
if you have too many signals that cross
the threshold or too many units whose
activation crosses the threshold you're
going to get more interference when you
train or if you have not not enough
neurons whose activation crosses the
threshold you're going to get
you're going to get that phenomenon
which you which you're showing on the
screen right now on the left side where
you where you have a drop in accuracy
because your representations don't have
enough capacity so that's why we we
opted to go for
um a fixed value of k but even if um you
know we we didn't have even if we did
have a threshold i think one of your
critiques were here um you know now we
have another hyper parameter k that
we're choosing in the other case i mean
we'd have to with our hyper parameter
would just be the threshold value there
right obviously yeah yeah um
so
to me this this continual learning setup
is is very cool and you can generate
data very easily using this permuted
mnist uh but there is an a bit of an
issue that i have and that is that
if i use permuted mnist there is another
thing there's like all the tasks are
like the same difficulty right they're
essentially the same task it's just
permuted so i need to learn
yes i need to learn like a different
function so this would be the
permutation identity and then the pixels
are permuted somehow right so all the
tasks are kind of the same right which
warrants a static network architecture
and every context vector is kind of the
same length right and all the dendrites
they can they can sort of specialize in
each of their little task recognition
what would change here or is it is this
a drastic requirement to your
architecture or do you think
if
many of the tasks were wildly different
from each other and you have this a
little bit in the robot example so what
can you tell about um when tasks are
very different in their difficulty
maybe in their amount of training data
like how do these things influence an
architecture that's targeted towards
continual learning
in our case um i think
there
there might actually be um similarities
between different tasks and so like you
know for example in in this case um in
permeated mnist right there there's a
there's a certain
certain pixels are more likely to be
white and certain figures are more
likely to be black depending on the
permutation so maybe you know
two different permutations could have
more overlap in terms of which pixels
are white which pixels are black or they
could be totally separate and if they're
uh more
if they're more similar
if the permutations are more similar
then we could expect that
the
the the sub networks that are selected
by the dendrites will probably have more
are likely to overlap more in which
neurons become active since there's a
lot of there's probably a lot of similar
computation going on but of course you
know in that case difficulty
doesn't really change
at all
i think to kind of add on to that i
think
a lot of it depends on the
quality of the contact signal because
ultimately that's the part of the
network that
indicates to the active dendrites what
kind of task you're solving how similar
is it to previous tasks you might have
seen and things like that
so i think that in this in this
permitted mnist case the way we're
computing the context does allow for
this property that karen just mentioned
where if there's some overlap in the
input space then the contact signal for
that will will demonstrate this input
and perhaps allow for overlapping
subnetworks to emerge whereas if you
have like wildly different tasks which
is something we see more in the robotics
environment then these context signals
can like differ more and uh indicate
that
the the sub networks must be like
must not overlap i think it would be
really interesting and we've talked
about this before to try a similar setup
in a continual like robotics learning
case where you have a streaming set of
like robotics tasks
and i think that would probably be a
super interesting study to do and
something that hopefully we will
try at some point in the future
so i had i had some observations with
respect to your experimental setup and
it's very cool that you do two different
things but there are also
noticeable differences on how you
implement the two different tasks right
in the first task you give the task id
directly
in the second tasks you do this this
this prototyping approach which is a
more advanced approach uh can you tell a
little bit about
how is there like a a reason why in
because i could also imagine you just
give me the task id in the second task
or i do the prototyping in the first
task is there like
a research process reason like did you
find that some things did work or didn't
work or how did this come about that all
of a sudden were introduced in the new
task we're introduced to this new way of
detecting the context
i think in the context of the
multi-agent like sorry the multi-task
reinforcement setup like
the environment setup itself gives the
task id and i think that the concept of
multitask learning itself is
more focused on if you have different
tasks which may conflict with one
another in terms of the types of
behavior you have to do with the types
of predictions can how can you
mathematically still optimize your like
joint objective function without
and still be able to perform well on all
the tasks and the problem shifts not so
much from trying to infer what task
you're doing to more
you know what task you're doing and you
want to try to do all of them how can we
like optimize this joint objective
and this is kind of the way we use this
one hot task encoding is in line with
past works that deal with multi-task
learning and multi-task reinforcement
learning
where you have this like one-hot task
encoding that is provided i do agree
that like the one hot encoding is quite
convenient and a little bit arbitrary
you can probably use like a denser
representation for each task or try to
infer it but i think for the purposes of
our experiments this
one hot encoding seemed
simple as it was environment provided
and
um
kind of like the point of the multi-task
setup was to again like try to show
that
this network architecture prevents from
like conflicting updates
across tasks and avoids this like
interfering
um updates from occurring i think for
continual learning the kind of
uh the kind of setup of the problem
itself
is is a little bit bigger and that you
have to you're not always provided with
the task ids and you have to infer this
on the fly uh which again i think karen
can talk a little bit more about
yeah in continual learning there are a
couple um other recent papers that have
come out in the last couple of years and
they're not
providing task id and then and the model
actually needs to infer the task id as
it does some sort of you know
modulation or or whatever their whatever
their technique is so we thought you
know that that makes the problem a bit
more challenging a bit more interesting
so since we are working on continual
learning and comparing to some of these
other methods let's also try to infer um
what the what the what the task should
be
so it's it's if i if i hear this
correctly it's very much inspired by the
environment itself like what what the
problem is supposed to be and not
like because if i see something like
this that i always have the vague
suspicion that people try something and
it didn't work and it's like well let's
try something else but there's also i
mean it's it's i don't want to infer
that so it's it's always good to hear
like okay this really came about through
the environment um
and i mean it would be equally cool if
it was the other thing but
i'm just always interested to hear so i
can adjust my priors uh
what i think just to add really quick
sorry just add really quickly i think in
the reinforcement learning setup as well
because the state space is like similar
it's shared across all the tasks because
essentially it's hard to infer from the
states what tasks you might be doing if
you weren't given such an id and the
only information you would have is like
the reward signal
and that might not be enough to like
infer what the task is
um so like appending giving attachment
ideas given that it's at the end right
yeah
it's like you know you do you do
something and then you get like a reward
and then you find out what task you just
did like that's okay i agree with you
that's really not helpful at all
also i think
one thing to add here is that we did try
a couple so i think this is something
you pointed out in your intro where um
the task ids that we're using are one
not encoded right at least for multitask
rl
and that means that all these tasks are
entirely orthogonal to each other and it
really doesn't reflect how similar one
task is to another
and it really doesn't also reflect how
different one task might be from another
so one thing that we were experimenting
with
i think we mentioned briefly in the
paper is that we tried having an
embedding layer that effectively embeds
this one-hot encode into some other
higher dimensional representation and
using this instead of that one-hot
encode as a context
and i think what we eventually found was
that
using the embedding or not using the
embedding produced fairly similar
results
so we just we just decided to remove it
for simplicity's sake
but one thing to note is that using the
embedding allows you to
represent contexts i think that are a
little bit more
nuanced in the sense that the embedding
since it's trained via end to end
backprop
any task that is similar to another task
would have a shared um representation in
that higher dimensional embedding and
ones that are really separate from each
other would likewise correspond to
huge distances apart in that higher
dimensional space
but the the one-handed code is entirely
orthogonal from from each other each
task but it still worked out pretty well
um compared to the embedding
i mean yeah and and if it gets more
complicated i think you could you could
put entire sub-neural networks uh you
know instead of that even that embedding
layer you could have non-linearities
inferring sort of uh more complicated
tasks
uh task embedding or task relations
it is it is interesting though with
respect to um
with respect to the the context itself
you learn these things
all of this through back prop and
my question oh i think i brought this up
is would this be like a candidate for
maybe unsupervised pre-training that you
sort of maybe collect episodes or
something in your multitask rl and then
just sort of decide based on this you
know how do we structure our dendritic
segments in order to recognize the
context maybe some sort of contrastive
objective for or anything like is this
something that came i i just blurt these
things out when i do the reviews right i
never know if they're entirely stupid or
if people have thought about it or and
discarded it is that something that is a
candidate
i don't think it's something that we
considered um but an interesting thing
to note is that if we did use this for
some kind of unsupervised pre-training
tactic is that when you're actually
fine-tuning the network your context
vectors are different so that's that's
that's something i think that would be
that would be the most important nuance
to investigate um i personally don't
know how well that would work if we
trained on a set of contexts that are
different during the unsupervised
portion and then use a totally different
set of contexts during the fine-tuning
procedure um
i would imagine that doesn't work well
um
so yeah
to add on to that i think uh yeah kind
of like when i when i heard you say that
in your review it was quite interesting
i think from the perspective of
reinforcement learning at a high level i
don't know if this will work out but it
would be quite quite cool to see if um
if you can train these dendritic
segments to either produce if you can
train them to recognize different
contexts and maybe guide exploration in
different ways based on the context in
an unsupervised manner and maybe like
do different things in different
contexts as an exploration strategy i
think that'd be super cool
again i think the challenge there would
be to like come up with a clever way of
generating context in an unsupervised
way so i think
that that should that that would be an
interesting area of uh of investigation
based on like how do you come up with
context signals in an unsupervised
manner a contrastive approach might be
cool there and given these contexts how
do you train these active dendrites to
modulate neurons um to do what you
wanted to do and i think
thinking about that in the asp in the
lens of exploration and rl could be
quite interesting
yeah you could sort of even prepare for
context that you hadn't considered
before
uh maybe new instructions in a in a
familiar environment or something like
this
you have this this notion of prototyping
to recognize the context which i found
very interesting because it's sort of an
it's kind of like an unsupervised online
way even like as the data streams in you
create these new prototypes and so on
and sure there's some hyper parameters
but i think my main concern is that
you know just taking the average of the
samples as they you know as they come in
right here it's going to work for
something very simple um like permuted
mnist or so but this gets to its limits
very quickly right uh if i think about
imagenet classification or so
it is it is
quite limited how
how can this idea be extended to
let's say arbitrary complexity like what
would i have to do with this online
prototyping approach to make it
a man like to to make it usable for more
complex problems
hey look i think you're absolutely right
that um this technique only works for
something like permeated mnist where you
get really good task separation um
through just averaging the examples from
a single task and that's why it works so
well here right we actually evaluated
how well uh how well this clustering
procedure works and it's like it works
pretty well it's not it's not
misclassifying things when when it's
clustering the prototypes but if we want
something that's a bit more general and
can apply to
other domains like um
like imagenet as you mentioned
i think something along the lines of
self-supervised learning might might
help there that way you know you're
you're trying to build build
a produ a context vector that is going
to provide you sufficiently good uh task
separation and it's not as simple as
just
just averaging
um does that does that get at your
question
yeah no absolutely
um
and i think also in like meta learning
in literature there are prototyping
methods that maybe like process the raw
input into an embedding space and then
do clustering similar to what we're
doing there so i think
uh that that would be a quite simple
approach that is similar in flavor to
this one but kind of embeds the
uh raw and put like an imagenet input
into some better clusterable space
is
another thing i noticed and this is a
minor thing but
here you feed the context signal
into both of your layers and in the
experiment before here you you draw this
very very accurately you feed the
context signal into only one of the
layers so it doesn't it doesn't go in
here is there a particular reason behind
the choice of this
yeah so there's a bit of background
regarding this um i want to say first
that the the continual learning and
reinforcement learning projects started
it started out as separate areas within
numenta and the goal for this was really
to see if the same principles of the
same model could work equally in both of
these areas so while we did modulate
both the layers in continual learning
the intuition for not doing so in
reinforcement learning was a bit
different it was that the first layer
should contain all the shared
information the model needs and that and
you could really do this without
activating any specific sub networks and
that the second layer would then
activate the context dependent sub
networks for each task um but you're
you're absolutely right that we could
have tried doing in-depth experiments
where we modulated both layers for the
for the rl setup i think we started
doing that at the beginning of this
project but
we found it worked reasonably well but
because of the time and computing
constraints of running each of these rl
experiments we decided to stick with the
original plan
and really pick a few key experiments
and key architectures to run and really
leave the ablations for the continual
learning experiments which are really
significantly faster to run
but you are absolutely right though
we just went off of our intuition on
this one
i mean i don't want to like this is it's
it's just my reviewer too popping up and
be like hey you know
[Laughter]
but it's good i mean it's it's even
interesting to see yeah that this this
is kind of a convergence of projects
could you tell us a little bit more
about just the research process you you
already talked about how this came to be
but
like the process of of researching this
it's it's kind of a new thing right you
you propose a new architecture the tasks
are let's say not that mainstream people
work on them but they're not super
mainstream um
like is it was it like smooth sailing
from beginning to end like stepwise
improvement or was there points that
just didn't work at all for a long time
are there
entire avenues that you discarded
and didn't didn't end up working out
like could you
i don't know let other people
i don't know what you what you can or
want to disclose but it's always
interesting to hear you know what also
didn't work out during a project
yeah i can i can um start off um you
know when we first tried implementing
some of these ideas behind dendrites uh
you know you noticed that uh you know we
talk about this um this that we're
picking the maximum uh dendritic
activation and then um
and we're using that to modulate but
actually you know it was through the
process of trial and error that we
realized that um we were you know we
were just working on an initial toy task
we weren't um we weren't working on
continual learning back then we found
that hey we actually can't um uh we
actually can't turn things off we can
only turn them on because you are
picking the maximum value right so how
do you get how do you get something that
superspires so we actually want to turn
things off so he's like oh okay let's go
back and let's actually
not just pick the maximum but pick the
maximum and keep the sign so if
something's
really negative we're picking that and
so there's a whole appendix section um
and that's
actually the detail of how that that's
in the details of how we're actually
implementing this so through a bit of
trial and error and then also with um uh
you know picking the pro going back to
the prototype uh you know for a while we
were thinking well you know how can we
get something that um really provides
sufficient task differentiation so we
tried a bunch of different things uh you
know we um
just like just like abby mentioned he
had um he had a linear embedding which
was created from from his context we
also had one for continual learning but
that didn't really work real too well
either and we ended up settling
converging on something that's really
dumb and simple for permeated amnest
that ended up working out um
yeah
there's actually um just based off of
what karen was saying if you go to
figure 11 i think you had some points
there as well um
it's a visualization if i remember
correctly yeah this one 11. yeah um so
if you notice like we use the exact same
gating technique for both continual
learning and multi-task reinforcement
learning and that's the absolute max
skating so
you're picking not only the absolute max
but you're you're retaining the sign
and what you'll notice is that the
initial intuition for doing this was
that as current just said is you want to
give each neuron the ability to either
turn on or turn off
and it's very interesting because if you
look at the results in multitask rl you
can see that for neuron b at least you
see some negative activations those red
squares that you see so that's
effectively the the neuron being told to
turn off uh it's the exact opposite of a
positive a strongly positive activation
but i think what's something that's very
interesting to see is at least for the
two neurons that we've showed for um
continual learning on the right hand
side you don't really see that happening
it's either the neuron doesn't receive
high magnitudes of activation or it
receives really high magnitudes but it's
all positive
so something interesting to note that we
were even even in the in the multitask
rl part we were working trying to
understand would max skating work better
than absolute max skating uh in the
sense that do we want to discard the
sign or keep design um
so yeah it's there's a lot of um in the
beginning there was a lot of trial and
error process um in multitask rl 2 we
had a a good amount of time spent on
understanding what the right sparsity
levels were to uh to apply for the the
weights parsing the feed forward layers
um what we what we saw i think is is
also pretty sort of it's intuitive if
you really increase your sparsity level
to uh to a really high sparsity there's
just not enough information in the
network to keep training and your your
accuracy sort of plummets but something
that's interesting to note is that
there's always a sweet spot for for
sparsity um and once you reach there
it's
that's that's when accuracy is the best
and how do you
what how do you debug these things what
is your main method is your main method
mainly setting a parameter and then
running things or what what are good
ways to like are there good ways to peak
inside and what's happening like what
are things that you look at to debug
something like this like oh we are not
sparse enough or we're too sparse or we
don't turn off neurons or something like
this
i think diagrams like this which you
have on your screen are a perfect
example um you know visualizations of
how the how the dendrites are behaving
so i think there was at one point um
early on uh you know here here you hear
you have in both cases after learning
that you know different segments are
responding uh to different tasks
uh context but there are cases where
this uh early on where these diagrams
looked looked exactly like um
just um just really just
horizontal bars right so you have the
same segment that's just winning all the
time and so you're like so we realized
okay well this is not right we don't
want the same segment to always win so
um
that that helps in identifying okay this
is why the network is failing and so we
go back
you would look at these things even
during your research process it's not
just something that you made after the
fact uh just to demonstrate to the to
the readers yeah yeah oh yeah yeah this
was a very helpful tool for uh debugging
cool i mean that's really interesting to
hear right
and a lot of the architecture decisions
um that were made in continual learning
were used
um in in multi-task rl simply because i
think the each multi-task experiment
took 25 hours to run plus easily
so it was really hard to change a
parameter observe how the the results
and visualizations looked and then sort
of edit from there on so a lot of the
intuitions that that we got in rl came
from
curran's continual learning experiments
so that was that was nice
did you ever
compare these things to
well it's not it's not too easy to
compare but sort of a baseline because
there is the danger with these things
that you kind of interpret i think i
said well couldn't this be just like
a like the difference between the top
and the bottom just be you know one is
at initialization and one is trained and
maybe has not much to do with sparsity
did you ever compare this to
something that isn't explicitly sparse
or anything like this like is there
something you can you can say
as a reference point yeah so there's
there's two things to note there the
first is that at least for this
visualization the the activations are
normalized with respect to when they
were trained so it's i think you
mentioned this in your in your intro as
well you said that could it potentially
be that you have really high activations
in the beginning and the area that
you've circled there in purple it just
sort of sort of gets dimmed down and i
think the important thing to note is
they're all normalized so the range of
values between the highest uh activated
neurons are much higher than the lowest
activated neurons after training than
before training but to address the
second point you're i think that's
regarding figure 10 if you scroll up
um
and that was why don't we have like a
baseline for this
is it really that the active dendrites
networks that are creating these
hypersparse
subnetworks and to that you're you're
absolutely right we should have had a
nice diagram here that also showed how
this would look in a baseline mlp you're
absolutely right that's something that
we could definitely include
i mean i totally believe you that it's
like very sparse it's just that it's not
it's not obvious from a diagram like
this like what you know what what should
i expect i i yeah but
cool um yeah there is one one other
thing in that
by the way like i i have mad respect for
you for including the graph on the right
like like mad respect like
90
plus of researchers where they try
something like this specifically because
no one would notice if you leave this
away right no one no one comes to you
and says well okay maybe someone comes
to you but no no one would seriously
miss adding the the s i to both of these
things and you you know at the left you
beat them
very clearly so you know huge respect
for uh for including that that is it's
it's i think to be commended and to be
highlighted
i think um
you know when we present a new
architecture like this um you know we we
really want to show the community that
hey we can we can do things like
continual learning with our more
biologically inspired ideas
and it's competitive with what's already
out there right so even if we're not
beating the state of the art i think
that that's perfectly fine even though
you know nowadays a lot of machine
learning has turned into this
competition of you know getting getting
the best numbers uh and if you don't
have the best numbers apparently that
that means you you won't be able to
publish anymore so
yeah to add on to that i think
the purpose of this paper was really
something i said that we all said in the
beginning and now it's um
we really want to show a proof of
concept for this completely novel
architecture where the goal is really
not to get state-of-the-art activity on
either of these benchmarks
it's really about the the promise of
something new
something i think that deep learning is
has been missing for the past what 10
years or so so yeah it's exciting
and
the last thing maybe we we can get into
is this comparison to other to other
networks because you you you very
clearly address this in like a paragraph
um
and i think wait i i have like even a
transformer diagram somewhere you
clearly address this in a paragraph
saying like isn't this just equivalent
to to like a bigger network and i try to
myself also to come up with you know is
there some way i could do the
multiplication in like an mlp and i'm
i'm fairly convinced there isn't but
there is a connection clearly to like
lstms which do modulate things with like
forget gates and so on they even have
sigmoids right uh so they can they can
module model this this on or off
and uh also sparsity to an extent and i
also think that a transformer could
conceivably like a two-layer transformer
could conceivably model the interaction
right here did you explore
at all like the the inter like the
connections
of
sort of this active dendrites framework
to other models is there something you
can say about that
i definitely think that these are great
observations by the way that the kind of
relationship between attention
and transformers and like the gating and
lstms and gru's
there's definitely a relationship
between those mechanisms and what we're
doing here
i think
uh in our research process we definitely
thought a lot about how this skating
mechanism is could be related to like
things like multi-headed attention or
basically you're doing a similar thing
where you're matching keys and queries
as vectors with an inner product and
then using that as a way to see what
parts of a sequence for example to wait
when you're considering a certain
position i think the key difference in
terms of
i think the the the similarity is that
for for in the specific instance of
attention
you are using learned weights to match
uh a given input so for example in our
active dendrites you're matching the
context
with the set of uh dendritic segments
and then um
in attention you're matching like the
query vector with a set of keys
um i think that the key difference is
that
the purpose for which is it's done
here
in active dendrites you're looking at a
specific neuron and you're saying okay
given the context is this neuron
relevant in transformers you're saying
okay here's a position
what context around me in terms of the
in terms of the sentence for example is
relevant for me and how can i wait
certain aspects of it so i think it's a
little bit
like flipped in how
an interpretation like
of the focus
um kind of shifting to the lstm aspect i
think
my as a mechanism it's quite similar in
that the lstms actually like turn off or
turn on certain units themselves
um to carry forward in time
i think
yeah exactly that's what's done here i
think that the difference is now like
focus more on the sparsity aspect of it
in lstms you're trying to you're doing
like a weighted sum between what's in
the past and what's current and saying
okay let's pass this forward um and
there's no aspect of like using this to
enforce a level of sparsity
um here we're saying okay like let's
turn off certain things and do that in
order to remain sparse and pass forward
this information so there's definitely a
relationship there um i think the
interpretation is similar but a little
bit different
and i i think in all of these things uh
again to to highlight
lstms and transformers they're all
trained let's say with with backprop and
all the parameters are trained so still
you'd run into the same problems where
if you do discontinue learning tasks
would interfere with each other no
matter how much you know they can
implement the multiplication so that's
that's definitely definitely a
difference so in your in your um outlook
section i haven't mentioned this in the
video but you discuss sort of what to do
next and
i you mentioned a lot of like oh yeah we
want to investigate maybe
uh
the combination of rl and continual
learning and so on
is there something
that's here uh is there
is there
yeah you said um
you mentioned neuroscience a little bit
what would be
sort of the next big things from
neuroscience to include in deep learning
architectures
that aren't yet
really done by other people
like or is there something where you
know you could say well if we had that
uh that's not really in our deep
networks yet but if we had that that
would be like amazing
i think um this is a very small point um
but
the dendrites that we're sort of
modeling right now are they can be
considered the basal dendrites i think
you went over this briefly in your in
your intro
and the basal dendrites are responsible
for receiving this context and
depolarizing the the main cell to either
fire or not if that context was
recognized something that we haven't
looked into which could be potentially
interesting is modeling apical dendrites
and the apical dendrites receive
feedback either from uh they receive
feedback feedback from other cells that
also biases the the soma to fire or not
um i think that could be a potentially
interesting way to
to also gate each individual neuron
i think standard deep learning doesn't
do any of this anyway they only consider
the proximal dendrites which is um
mimicked by this simple linear weighted
sum to determine if the neuron is fired
but if we can gather all this other
neuroscience background from all the
other kinds of dendrites too like like
apical dendrites it could be a very
potentially interesting architecture
like a very powerful one for uh for
dynamic scenarios
i mean the issue of
top-down feedback or lateral lateral
inhibition or anything like this it's a
lot of people talk about it but i
haven't yet seen anyone successfully
sort of bring it into a deep network and
uh and actually do something useful with
it so yeah i definitely think you know
beyond dendrites uh just mechanisms like
this would be super helpful
i think like another aspect which is a
little bit
quite different from what avi just said
that would be quite interesting is
the the kind of local learning rule
aspects that are present in biological
neurons and how they might relate to
unsupervised learning in traditional
machine learning i think a lot of the
unsupervised learning objectives are
kind of addendums to the loss function
that we think might be useful and it
just kind of flows through the network
and kind of i don't think that i might
be wrong but i don't think there's a lot
of research into like figuring out which
parts of the network could focus on
certain things in an unsupervised way
which might be better done in biological
networks so i think
thinking about that
and
getting inspiration to see like what
kind of local learning rules in an
unsupervised way could improve
performance
and modern deep learning would be super
cool
cool um yeah so
do you have anything anything to add
anything people should know or that we
haven't talked about yet about the paper
people can get started with your code
which is online right i've seen that
which is very cool um yeah anything you
want to get off your like get out there
to the viewers
the take-home message um from this is
what we we want
what we want to be is is that um
the brain is you know able to do a lot
of different things it's using different
neural circuits to do it but you know
neural networks as they've been designed
uh decades ago they're really just
optimizing for one thing they're great
function approximators but you don't
just want to approximate one function
you want to be able to approximate
multiple functions
and so we want so we're trying to to
show that you know hey look there are
ways where we can get neural networks to
actually um you know have these have
different sub sub networks different
neural circuits that are able to uh be
independent be different uh function
approximators and if we can do that then
you know neural networks can will be
able to operate in more
more dynamic
changing
scenarios and i think that's that's
really exciting because the world is
constantly changing um but a lot of the
applications for deep learning right now
are a lot of the environments that they
operate and are static so if we can get
to that
then then that that that that's great
cool well akash karen abby thank you
very much for being here today uh this
was this was great fun and i learned a
lot yeah thanks
and now uh now you're influencing my uh
fashion
[Laughter]
nice
i'll join the i'll join the show
thanks so much for being here i yeah i
hope you i hope you continue this
because it's really cool and i think we
are we're missing it in deep learning
thanks annika that's
a pleasure thanks for having us
[Music]
you